F
PEOPLE FOR SOME TIME.
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU TONIGHT
THANK YOU.
NOW AS ABORTION DECISIONS MOVED
ENTERAL STATES THEY WASTED NO
TIME WITH PUTTING TRIGGER LAWS.
ONE OF THE STATES IS
SOUTH DAKOTA AND THE GOVERNOR
JOINS ME NOW GOVERNOR GREAT TO
SEE YOU TONIGHT.
YOURS IS ONE OF THE FEW STATES
MAKING ABORTION ILLEGAL
IMMEDIATELY WITH FEW EXCEPTIONS
IN RESPONSE TO THOSE INCLUDE IN
THE PRESENCE OF A CITY PUTS
WOMEN LIVES IN JEOPARDY.
>> WELL LAURA LET'S FORGET THAT
NOT FORGET THAT THAT IS A
WONDERFUL DAY.
SEVEN THAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE
WHINNIED MANY, MANY YEARS TO
HAVE HAPPEN THAT MANY LIVES WILL
BE SAVED.
AND SOUTH DAKOTA WAITED TRIGGER
LAW ALREADY IN STATUTE AND WHAT
IT SAYS IS THAT ABORTIONS WOULD
BE ILLEGAL EXCEPT TO SAVE THE
LIFE OF A MOTHER AT THE MOMENT
THAT ROE V. WADE WAS OVERTURNED.
SO AS OF TODAY THAT TRIGGER LAW
GOES INTO EFFECT WE ARE FOCUSING
A LOT ON SUPPORTING MOTHERS.
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS WHO FIND
THEMSELVES AN UNPLANNED
PREGNANCY OR PAYMENT SITUATION
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
CONNECTING THEM TO THE RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THE APPROACH
THAT YOUR STATE WILL TAKE IN THE
EVENT THAT A WOMAN SEEKS TO HAVE
A CHEMICAL ABORTION, OR
ABORTIONS OR MEDICATION, MAY
BEGET MEDICATION TO THE MALE I
THINK FOR A LOT OF DEMOCRATS SAY
SAYING THAT THEY WILL NOT ALLOW
THAT TO STOP OR BE STOPPED BY
THE STATE IN OTHER WORDS YES
INTERSTATE MALE AND SO FORTH.
WHAT WOULD YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT
BE?
>> THE STATURE AND THE LINKAGE
WE USE WILL BE SPECIFIC TO BEING
UTILIZED.
THIS CAN BE REFERENCED TO THE
DOES NOT SAVE THE LIFE OF A
MOTHER SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I AM LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS HAVE BEEN WORKING ON.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE WILL CALL
INTO A SPECIAL SESSION BECAUSE
OF THIS DECISION THAT JUST CAME
OUT TODAY AND THERE MAY BE SOME
LANGUAGE THAT WE WANT TO ADDRESS
DURING THAT SPECIAL SESSION AND
ALSO I LAUNCHED A WEBSITE TODAY
CALLED LIFE THAT SE,.GOV.
PUTS RESOURCES THERE TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN THESE
SITUATIONS AND IT CONNECTS THEM
TO MEDICAL HELP.
IT PUT SOME TOWARDS ADOPTIVE
SERVICES SO THEY DO HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED AT
THEIR FINGERTIPS.
LAURA THIS YEAR AND THE DEFLATE
OF SESSION I BROUGHT A BILL THAT
DEALT WITH CHEMICAL ABORTIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WERE TO BE
PROTECTED FROM THIS DANGEROUS
SITUATION OF GETTING STRUCTURED
THE MAIL BEING UNSUPERVISED FOR
THAT MEDICAL PROCEDURE.
>> Laura: WOULD TO BE A
POTENTIAL CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
DOCTORS AND/OR WOMEN WHO OBTAIN
AN ABORTION IN THAT MANNER?
OR CONDUCT AN ABORTION CONTRARY
TO STATE LAW?
>> OUR PENALTIES ARE ON THE
DOCTOR WHO PERFORMS THE ABORTION
OUTING OR MESSAGE FOR TODAY
SHOULD EVER BE ON PUNISHING
MOTHERS I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
WE FOCUS ON MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE DOCTORS AREN'T KNOWINGLY
PERFORMING ABORTIONS WHEN IT'S
AGAINST A LOT THAT THEY ARE
PUNISHED AND THAT SOME OF THE
STATUTES THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT
AS WE GO TO A SPECIA